una área de 8 veces el tamaño del gran
londres destruida por la deforestación
los datos de la agencia de investigación
espacial de brasil revelan que la tala
ilegal en la amazonía aumentó en casi un
22% en el último año el nivel más alto
en 15 años el ministerio del medio
ambiente de brasil prometió continuar
luchando son números aínda estos números
siguen siendo un desafío para nosotros y
tendremos que ser más contundentes con
relación a estos crímenes y seguro que
ampliaremos nuestras acciones y haremos
actuación entre 2009 y 2014 la amazonía
brasileña tuvo las tasas de
deforestación más bajas jamás
registradas pero los niveles comenzaron
a aumentar nuevamente cuando el
presidente yair bolsonaro asumió el
cargo en 2019 la oposición culpa que el
mandatario ha fomentado las actividades
agrícolas y mineras en términos más
generales las ong y los grupos indígenas
también lo acusan de debilitar las
salvaguardias ambientales en el foro
invertir en brasil que se llevó a cabo
esta semana en dubai funcionario dijo
que su país ha sido atacado injustamente
en lo que a la selva amazónica se
refiere y afirmó que era demasiado para
incendiarse
los ojos los ataques que sufre brasil
cuando se trata de la amazonía no
está allí se conserva más del 90% de esa
área está exactamente igual que cuando
fue descubierta en 1500 y la amazonía es
fantástica amazon es fantástica
bolsonaro estuvo ausente de la reciente
cumbre climática en glasgow pero en el
evento sus delegados se comprometieron a
detener y revertir la pérdida de bosques
para 2030 los árboles de la amazona se
absorben grandes cantidades de dióxido
de carbono que calentarían aún más el
planeta pero cuando se talan o se queman
ese mismo carbono se libera rápidamente
a la atmósfera